how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week one
that's it one drink one shelf you're
just
an alcoholic with a great voice careful
lemon you're playing with fire
is this everybody and took a cab tom's
in the trunk jerry's on the roof
all right where to first your mother's
butt
so alone if even one of you thinks about
dry heaven in my car you're all walking
home
okay we just need to hire some of those
ugly people who have the paper and
change the shapes on it
writers no we'll do the work ourselves
meet me in my dressing room i'll get a
computer from one of the ugly people
and i'll bring the world's greatest
encyclopedia
my mind all my life
i have avoided europe and its multitudes
of terribleness
but it turns out much to my surprise
there is actually one place in europe
that is worth seeing
[Music]
these tiny islands off the coast of
scotland where god's chosen elixirs are
distilled
barreled and prepared for consumption
this
is worth the trip word is the board is
meeting later this week
guys must be close to making a decision
i wouldn't know anything about that
hey guys let's change the subject to
sucking at golf so donaghy has something
to talk about
[Laughter]
i'm sorry about that i'm a little
nervous don't apologize you're a natural
i'm feeling pretty drunk well it's
business drunk it's like rich struck
either way it's legal to drive
hey ron morning leslie
do you have a good night i did i watched
a really good document what is that
this is what i did last night after i
got home i drank six more glasses of
whiskey
and then i finished crafting this small
harp using a band saw a spoke shave
and an oscillating spindle sander
beautiful but wait there's more here are
some photographs of me drinking the
whiskey
you'll notice i'm holding up yesterday's
newspaper so you can tell that i'm not
lying
i feel like i'm in a spa
hey jack did you dye your hair no
no so how was your new year's
wonderful my dear friend the deepsea
explorer bob ballard brought over a 2
000 year old m4
of wine from a sunken phoenician trading
vessel
the wine turned out to be quite toxic
my guests and i spent the stroke of
midnight in my garden
vomiting oh my god sorry don't be the
whole night
purging the new year the vivid
hallucinations of astarte
the phoenician goddess of sex and war at
all
wipe the slate clean everybody pants now
pants
pants buns pants pants she's had enough
call it off that's not how it works
she's out
wait i'm subbing in april no that stuff
will melt the shell off a garden snail
whatever
i'm puerto rican i can handle it
oh my god okay this ends now
so
yeah mom you're going back to the farm
and you you're going back to hell i
uh what's wrong with joan she has a bad
hangover
which she is pretending as allergies is
she gonna be okay
wouldn't know never been hung over after
i've had too much whiskey i cook myself
a large flank steak pan-fried and salted
butter
i eat that put on a pair of wet socks
and go to sleep that works
it does
you